savez vous que le mexique est le pays de
la tomate mais aussi du chocolat
alors si vous voulez bien restons bien
français intéressons-nous justement à la
cuisine mexicaine l'image de cette
cuisine l'image traditionnelle et bien
c'est la cuisine très épicé avec les
traditionnelles sauce aux piments j'en
ai une dans les mains mais sur place
nous avons connu d'excellentes surprises
la cuisine y est fort bonne abondante on
peut parler sans crainte de gastronomie
à l'image de l'ensemble du pays la
cuisine mexicaine est d'une extrême
diversité
si l'on pense automatiquement bien sûr à
la puissance des places c'est-à-dire au
piment on oublie trop souvent que du
poulet au chocolat et aux épices à la
purée d'avocat voit tous les tacos c'est
à dire les crêpes de maïs et puis enfin
les fruits la cuisine de ce pays reflète
bien la taille et les climats du mexique
rappelez vous tout d'abord que le pays
est grand comme quatre fois la france et
qu'il comporte pas moins de 24 états
c'est dire qu'il comporte également une
extrême variété de climats de vue c'est
au plus humide que les bords de mer
également sont importantes
en conséquence on rencontre un peu tous
les légumes tous les condiments mais
aussi toutes les viandes
il est donc possible de très bien mangé
attention c'est souvent copieux mais
aussi de manger mexicain l'arrivée des
hamburgers symbole de la civilisation
américaine se fait mais entre la
tradition et l'américanisme la cuisine
mexicaine trouve sa voie à combien on
jouera contre il existe bien sûr une
cuisine traditionnelle qui trouve
d'ailleurs son origine dans la
civilisation pré hispanique
cela remonte très loin dans le temps
mais c'est vrai aussi la cuisine moderne
a tendance à s'internationaliser quelque
peu des techniques se sont peu à peu
modifié en particulier sous l'influencé
espagnole
cela précisé il faut dire tout de même
que l'alimentation de base de la
population mexicaine elle ne s'est pas
vraiment modifié
l'ex-international musicale au quai à
conteneurs américaine